- You're around athletes a lot.
So many of them have
pregame rituals. Right?
So what do you do before
you hit the field?
Like for interviews? What do you do?
- So what I do before I hit the field,
I always call my dad because--
- I love this about you.
- I know, I love that. Thank you.
Yeah, he's my best friend.
And he knows so much about sports,
and like he's the one that
got me interested in it.
Used to tell me all the
stories all the time
about the athletes, the
coaches, all the things.
And then I listened to
really dirty rap music.
(kelly laughing)
Really explicit.
- You're like Gweneth Paltrow.
She was on here and
asked her favorite song,
and she said, "WP."
- Yeah! Or "Up."
But I love like the pre,
pre-game before the fans come in
and the guys are just warming up,
when they're FaceTiming their
families and all the things.
They like to put on their music.
And so I'm always like going
to talk to somebody I'm like,
"Hold on, let me Shazam this."
It's like, "Oo, this is dirty and fun."
(audience laughing)
I love this.
- Wait, who's like your
favorite to listen to?
- I don't know anyone
who's just like, really...
- I like Kendrick Lamar.
- Yes! So do I. So do I.
Cardi B's fantastic.
I'll never know all the words.
Nicki Minaj. Fantastic.
Like, just the fact that they, you know,
all the beats and everything.
And I think I'm so cool
when I listened to it.
I pretend I'm a football player so.
- Oh my god. I pretend I'm them,
like while they're singing,
cause it takes God,
Jesus, the Holy Spirit,
everything to keep me on a treadmill.
And also, also rap music.
No, I just used to love it.
And now I don't and I'm just like,
"Oh my god, there's so many things
I'd rather be doing right now.
But, Okay. Cool, for my heart, whatever."
But like, so I do it
and I listen to a lot
of Kendrick and Cardi.
They're good to listen
to, but I feel bad ass.
I have to feel bad ass.
- That's what I'm saying.
And I like to feel that
way before I go in front
of the camera to do a game.
And I also to make me feel like a kid,
I eat like one of those Uncrustables,
like a peanut butter and
jelly sandwich, because--
- I've heard this about you.
Actually, you take kid
snack food for your food.
It's awesome.
- Well, think about it. Down on the field,
I don't have much time cause
I'm running in after a coach
or I'm running out with a coach.
I can't it's...
I used to back in the day,
I'll crush a hot dog or chicken
fingers or all the things,
but I don't have time.
Uncrustables are so easy.
They come in that plastic wrap
and you can just eat so fast.
And what's better than a PB and J
when you're standing there for seven hours
and you need something to eat.
- Yeah. Something.
Yes. Well, I heard this about you.
So I stole some food from my son's lunch.
I brought you...
- I love you. What flavor? Do you know?
- It's a secret. It's a surprise.
- You just have the best
snacks when you come here.